this is a peaceful serene place and
these people come from Los Angeles
County and invade there was a loud
banging on the back gate and I said
what's going on it goes we have a
warrant to search the premises and then
they drew their guns
I was scared I didn't know what was
going on one of my worst days one of my
family's worst days
at this armed raid uncovered a weapons
stockpile foiled a terrorist plot know
what government agents were after was
this raw milk a danger to society or so
the Food and Drug Administration tells
us the FDA warns raw milk can cause
vomiting diarrhea and worse but not
everyone is so worried about these risks
all Romney Rockies greens eggs it's pure
and healthy and makes me feel good this
is rawesome foods a private membership
Club in Venice California before
entering members sign a waiver stating
that they actually want food that has
not been heated or pasteurized
in fact that's the whole point explains
the club's manager James Stewart
it's how nature provides the food
without the man becoming involved in
pasteurization homogenize a ssin
processing of any kind the class of
foods most scrutinized it seems to us is
anything having to do with raw dairy raw
milk whether it's cow or goat in the
past three years there have been at
least eight government raids across the
u.s. involving raw dairy according to
the farm to consumer legal defense fund
in this security camera footage we see
agents entering Rossum's kitchen guns
drawn
Jarell winter haka manager has worked at
frost for four years and was there the
morning of the raid we heard a Buy in on
the back door one of my workers helpers
he went on is hey there's cops out here
the police presented a warrant so
Terrell let them in they made me get out
of the kitchen and I had to go sit over
there on a chair and they searched me
they started walking around they drew
their guns and I'm like why why are you
drawing guns I didn't know what was
going on I mean it seemed like they
thought we had cocaine in the papayas or
something guns drawn is is way beyond
and above the colony the raid on Rossum
involved no less than five government
agencies the FDA that Los Angeles Health
Department the Los Angeles Sheriff's
Department the Los Angeles District
Attorney's Office and the California
Department of Food and Agriculture all
five of these agencies declined
interviews for this story saying the
investigation was ongoing
the agents proceeded to collect what
they called samples for the case they
took 24 jars of the same kind of money
for what purposes you're taking a sample
of something you need one jar of that
honey not 24 they just went into our
freezer and they just took gallons and
cheeses and whatever they wanted
the delivery left this door open and the
curtains open so I would spoil the food
and they knew this by the end of the day
they kept it over for so long that a lot
of stuff had gone hotnet couldn't sell
it thousands and thousands of dollars
worth of food they don't want to see
this happen they want to stop this from
happening they're going to shut us down
whenever they can in whatever way they
can
the agents were collecting samples of
goods supplied to Rossum by this Santa
Paula farm and this Santa Paula
operation is where the story really
begins
Sharon Palmer and her three children run
healthy family farms which has long been
under the scrutiny of various agencies
for its sale of raw goat milk
Rossum had a real desperate need for a
raw goat milk and we progressed in
building our own dairy and raising our
own goats because of Palmer's work with
raw goat milk the farm was rated and she
was arrested my children stood by and
watch me in handcuffs people that I had
volunteers here just stood back and just
har they took me down to the county jail
booked me photographed me like a
criminal
Palmer spent the night in the Ventura
County Jail and was never charged that
happened in 2008 she was rated again in
2009 and again in 2010 that raid was
coordinated with the raid 70 miles away
and raw seafoods in Venice my kids were
getting dressed every was getting ready
for school knock on the door they
proceeded to come on into the house get
everybody out of bed in the pajamas tell
us that they're searching and raiding
the farm ripped my house apart all of
our records volunteers on the farm
neighbor's picking tomatoes chased off
this is a peaceful serene place and
these people come from Los Angeles
County and in
you had over 50 state and county
employees raiding this farm and Rossum
at the same time to look at the money
that these taxpayers are paying for Los
Angeles County District Attorney Los
Angeles County police the Sheriff's
Department you tell me how much we paid
for that it was only after this last
raid that the Sheriff's Department got
around to charging her the offense
improperly labeling her cheese products
a misdemeanor but still enough to
suspend her dairy license our raw foods
better for you than pasteurized ones the
science is out on that question but
here's another question should we be
allowed to decide what we put into our
own bodies this is America how do you
going to tell me what I shouldn't repeat
we are a private membership club and
people who are here want to be a part of
this club this is about people putting
food into their bodies and when it gets
down to the point of people not being
able to make a choice that they want to
put into their own bodies people are
going to stand up and say I don't think
so we should have the right to choose if
we want to eat raw salmon sushi or
cooked hamburgers we should have the
right to be able to go to McDonald's or
go to Rossum for now no charges have yet
resulted from the raid on Raza but yet
another agency Los Angeles Building and
Safety is threatening to shut them down
this time for illegal structures on the
property
Sharon Palmer plans to fight the
misdemeanor charge stemming from her
cheese's label she's raising baby goats
in the hopes that she'll one day be
allowed to sell her dairy for reason TV
I'm Zach Weissmuller